I'm Frankie Francisco my name is Wyatt
and my name is Roxanne we are here to
play screw marry or kill yes Queen oh I
already got mine this one's easy
this is a good picture of Shawn Mendes
well I know I actually barely yeah Shawn
Mendes you see this this is a great big
reveal are we thinking the same thing
first okay right here at 1 2 3 Taylor
Swift as Tara sorry this is actually
really difficult
I don't even know what it is you know
where there's no hostess this is Shawn
Mendes Oh Oh can I just kill multiple
people kill Cochise okay you choose like
screw oh I think you're choosing yes on
you and you sleeping on the couch
there's one first there's a [ __ ] guy
this tables Lardner I guess I would have
sex with John Landis off a screw and
then we're gonna marry Beyonce because
she has money
like what Bianchi owns the money huh you
see in it for the money
yeah I love her too but it's a different
type of love that would last forever in
like ears beds of money you know okay
Mary I agree
Mary Mary Beyonce screw Shawn Mendes
yeah beautiful man I don't want to look
at your you yeah I'd have to kill Taylor
Swift you can go the Queen No okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna be kept clear yeah yeah
I'm gonna kill Shawn Mendes cuz I Kevin
Kline is just a girl that's a game screw
Taylor Swift just good get have sex with
Taylor Swift maybe and they gonna marry
the Queen because just the Queen Oh
screw just look at interests like
super-handsome mix James Bond
hopefully we're hoping I said marry for
what's her name save her long Jennifer
Lawrence hey I'm sorry
she looks like she has money I've seen
her in a couple film and there's a
silver lining there too so and then kill
I was kind of like the last option for
me so I think it Mary Eater selva I
don't know who's gonna top I feel like
maybe like screw screw
okay look it's like I don't watch Game
of Thrones not really my vibe I don't
know
I'm gonna go with Mary definitely going
marry him because this guy is a
good-looking guy I don't know this guy
looks like he's like wise and refined
over this guy yeah I feel like he he
looks like a wise refinement I think I'm
have to agree with you I might I might
actually screw this guy messing wise
we're gonna kill Kay Harrington because
Game of Thrones not my show not into
medieval stuff these are multiple people
we got all these people screw all of
them well there's a little designer
sex with the Avengers come on better get
my Infinity stones let me tell you I
would clearly kill the Kardashians
like it's not even need to begin and
then Harry Potter is this not very all
advanced there I'll be cool like a
magical wedding in London
this one is easy for me I'm just gonna
go I'm gonna screw the Kardashians 100%
we're gonna marry the Avengers fam cuz
endgame was ridiculously good and we're
gonna kill Harry Potter they're just a
little too old nowadays yeah I gonna say
screw the Avengers the whole point
brother mark roughly there's anyone in
30 it's a totally I can't cure the quite
I shouldn't right now but they're just
so awfully amazing to like following
that so Mary you were in and then I just
watched every part or so I'm fighting
they're impervious to death by okay
I'd say I'd also killed the cast of
Harry Potter
never in the books kind of behind on the
movies and I know is that sad no I'm
gonna need some marry into the
Kardashians
we're gonna go marry Kardashians I'll be
iconic and screw the adventures he goes
for The Avengers cast I really am
surprised that he is going to marry the
Kardashians but I'm not that sub Christ
you did say marry whatever as long as I
get some of the wealth that's all that
happened to me I'm surprised that he
said he'd screw the Kardashians usually
it's like pretending he was like not
attracted to them or they're too
dramatic so expose expires
[Music]